[Música]
este sábado el presidente de Chile
cumple su primer año al mando del país y
en la previa el mandatario realizó un
segundo cambio en su gabinete Boris sacó
del cargo a cinco ministros entre ellos
a la canciller la medida es considerada
como un giro hacia el centro por parte
del político de izquierda
culminó a México la segunda fase de la
mesa de diálogos entre el gobierno de
Colombia y la guerrilla del ejército de
liberación nacional con avances de Cara
a un eventual cese el fuego tras esta
ronda El Ejecutivo de Gustavo Petro
reconoció el estatus político del eln
como una organización Armada rebelde
el presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel
López Obrador prometió una investigación
profunda sobre el secuestro de cuatro
ciudadanos estadounidenses dos de los
cuales fueron asesinados en el país
según el mandatario el prestigio de
México está en juego cinco presuntos
responsables del plagio fueron detenidos
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Chile el presidente Gabriel Boris
anunció una esperada reforma de su
gabinete ejecutivo el mandatario cambió
a los titulares de exteriores Obras
Públicas culturas deportes y ciencia
Boris descartó que la renovación se deba
a presiones internas de la coalición del
gobierno y por el contrario dijo que
respondían a la necesidad de contar con
personas con conocimiento del Estado su
decisión se dio a un día de cumplir el
primer aniversario de su toma de
Posesión previamente hablamos con
Nicolás freire si encista político y
académico con quien analizamos qué
logros ha alcanzado Boris durante su
primer año y Qué desafíos tiene por
delante
Mira yo creo que cumple un año y hace
dos días se cayó la reforma madre de
todo el programa de gobierno del
presidente borich es decir no obstante
haya recuperado la percepción positiva
por parte de la ciudadanía en el último
tiempo sobre todo a partir de la gestión
de algunos de sus ministros y ministras
en los incendios que afectaron el sur de
país en febrero y ha subido en las
encuestas Lamentablemente hace dos días
fue rechazada la reforma tributaria y la
reforma tributaria era una condicionante
particular respecto de la implementación
de todo el programa de gobierno por
tanto este gabinete ASUME con la difícil
tarea de Buscar implementar reformas o
simplemente proyectos de ley ya ni
siquiera reformas profundas sin tener
las espaldas cubiertas con una reforma
tributaria que permita financiarlas
entonces este yo creo que va a ser un
gabinete que más bien va a tener que
sortear obstáculos tratar de Navegar lo
más tranquilo posible pero de ahí a
hablar Que sea un gabinete que pueda
imprimir una velocidad mayor para
conseguir las metas y objetivos que está
acá que este gobierno se ha planteado
desde el inicio yo sinceramente lo veo
bastante difícil este viernes finalizó
en Ciudad de México la segunda fase de
la mesa de diálogos de paz entre el
gobierno de Colombia y la guerrilla del
eln el ejército de liberación nacional
entre las conclusiones de esta ronda El
Ejecutivo de Petro reconoció el estatus
político del eln como una organización
Armada Rebelde y ambas partes mostraron
un optimismo moderado de cara al
objetivo de un acuerdo para el ces el
fuego bilateral recordemos que en 2019
el gobierno de Iván Duque suspendió las
negociaciones con la guerrilla y que la
administración de Petro las retomó en
2022 con el auspicio de Cuba Noruega y
Venezuela como países garantes
Más allá de la construcción de este
derrotero pudimos abordar
los temas más urgentes y sentidos y
sensibles como el cese al fuego
es un reclamo de de la de toda la nación
colombiana paren la violencia señores
armados además de acordar la nueva
agenda iniciamos a desarrollar el primer
punto referido a la participación de la
sociedad y la construcción de la paz
Asimismo dimos los primeros pasos para
concretar un cese al fuego bilateral
nacional y temporal que creará mejores
condiciones para la movilización y
participación de los colombianos en el
proceso de paz vamos a Estados Unidos
aún ante la falta de un anuncio oficial
sobre su candidatura a la casa blanca el
gobernador de Florida ron de santis
visitó el estado de Iowa para tantear el
terreno su viaje hace parte de una serie
de eventos que ha organizado en todo el
país y lo hace antes de que el
expresidente Donald Trump llegue allí
para un acto de campaña de Santi se
refirió a una multitud que escuchó
atenta sus críticas contra la
administración biden Iowa podría ser
clave para el gobernador a la hora de
buscar la nominación republicana
en México el presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador se refirió nuevamente al
secuestro de los cuatro ciudadanos
estadounidenses la semana pasada dos de
los cuales fueron asesinados y anunció
una investigación al respecto su anuncio
se da el mismo día en que las
autoridades informaron que cinco
personas habían sido arrestadas por este
caso Hazlo también dijo que el
secretario de relaciones exteriores
mexicano Marcelo ebrard viajará a
Washington para informar sobre los
esfuerzos en la lucha para detener el
tráfico de fentanilo
que como es un asunto
importante
porque está de por medio pues
el prestigio de nuestro país y del
gobierno
tenemos que ir a fondo
conocer
la verdad en Brasil el Instituto
Nacional de estudios espaciales informó
sobre un récord en deforestación de la
amazonía en el mes de febrero El
Ejecutivo de Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
prometió acabar con la minería ilegal y
la deforestación para lo que tendrá que
enfrentar diversos retos Alba Santana
tiene los detalles
malas noticias para la amazonía de
Brasil este febrero se registró un pico
de deforestación que batió el récord del
mes con un aumento del 62% respecto al
mismo en 2022 así lo indicó el Instituto
Nacional de estudios espaciales tras la
observación a satelital de la zona una
dinámica que se viene repitiendo los
últimos meses en el mayor bosque húmedo
del mundo aunque esta vez con una
diferencia crucial bajo el mandato del
izquierdista Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
nuestra mente es alcanzar la
deforestación 0 en la amazonía la
emisión cero de gases de efecto
invernadero en materia energética
una de sus promesas desde que juramentó
como presidente de Brasil el 1 de enero
fue terminar con la minería ilegal y
curvar la deforestación Pero eso no es
tan sencillo de hecho es un camino
plagado de retos el gabinete de Lula
deberá reconstruir las políticas y
organismos públicos de control tras los
cuatro años de desmantelamiento de
bolsonaro incrementar
aún más los esfuerzos por acabar con la
minería ilegal en la zona con redadas y
acción militar no obstante los expertos
advierten que reducir la deforestación
en la amazonía podría tomar años
acabamos de dejar atrás Un gobierno que
apoyó la deforestación y que abandonó
completamente acciones para controlarla
mientras las autoridades no controlen la
región por completo los mineros ilegales
pueden aprovechar esto para aumentar la
deforestación
el mes pasado El Ejecutivo de Lula pasó
a la acción y sacó a miles de Mineros
ilegales de la reserva indígena
llanomami pero las cifras indican que
tendrá que aumentar sus esfuerzos si
quiere ver cambios significativos para
el bosque tormentas de arena ciclones
incluyendo uno que podría ser el más
largo de la historia Nevada su
inundaciones están azotando al mundo
entero desde Perú hasta Madagascar el
clima desafía la respuesta de las
autoridades se rescatistas y dejas
centenares de víctimas de su Furia pero
también de condiciones agravadas por la
actividad humana repasamos la jornada en
el siguiente informe de eumar
el planeta a Merced de los elementos en
Perú el ciclón yacua devastado
poblaciones del Norte dejando muertos
desaparecidos más de 200 damnificados y
miles aislados es un fenómeno que no se
daba en el país de se hacía al menos 25
años miren Cómo la vecina del agua le ha
entrado los desagües dentro de su casa
no hay desagües donde pueda ir el agua
no hay lugares donde pueda haber
Sumidero donde el agua discurra qué es
esto estamos muy mal en California las
lluvias también han causado estragos con
desbordamiento de ríos al norte del
estado que han inundado carreteras e
incluso obligado a tomar previsiones de
Cara a una de las noches más esperadas
del año la de los premios de la academia
esperamos lluvia cada año y también
esperamos lo mejor hay pronósticos de
sol para el domingo poca lluvia hoy y
mañana pero en la programación nos da la
oportunidad de probar el sistema y
prepararnos si realmente llueve
es una prueba mucho más sencilla que la
que están soportando varios países
alrededor del océano Índico el ciclón
Freddy se mantiene activo desde el 6 de
febrero deja más de 20 muertos entre
mozambique y Madagascar ha afectado a
cientos de miles entre zimbabwes zambia
y malawi y solo espera la certificación
como el ciclón más largo de la historia
names fue declarado ciclón tropical hace
33 días hemos recibido Muchas preguntas
acerca de si es un récord o no la
Organización meteorológica Mundial está
preparando un comité de expertos para
evaluarlo
al norte del Atlántico muchas ciudades
se preguntan Dónde está la primavera
como sheffield en Reino Unido donde este
viernes han caído más de 33 centímetros
de nieve o Michigan en Estados Unidos
donde ha sido necesario palear la nieve
para habilitar el aeropuerto en Beijing
la contaminación se ha combinado con
tormentas de arena desde el desierto de
gobi para dejar a la ciudad envuelta en
una capa de polvo y la calidad del aire
tan empobrecida que es potencialmente
peligrosa para la salud y es que en el
mundo entero la mano del hombre agrava
la furia de la naturaleza hasta que es
informativo Gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]